the iPhone 5c is in many ways what you
have all been looking for
sleek efficient and harmonious with
design and technological intellect as a
senior VP of design and Apple I know
what you think this is the same [ __ ]
you've seen over and over again well
you're right I can't believe you guys
keep buying our products we haven't done
anything new in like the past six years
remember when we added video
capabilities to iPhone and every single
one of you were like em again phones had
video capabilities for the years by then
why were you so surprised you see at
Apple we like to add [ __ ] a little bit
behind so every time we breed something
out you think it's a new innovation and
it's not and you keep falling for it you
know what we do to get you guys we
always get some dude with a thick
British accent to explain the technology
because it makes a scene more legit
watch this Edward why don't you come in
for a second okay this is what I want
you to do on what you read the script
and we did in a British accent go
comfort comfort on this ship just do
with a case right I can't even do first
accent do it this phone is amazing
before it was made with a beautiful
metal now it's made with the Fantastic
Fest
this [ __ ] I can't do this I said British
not dumbass you idiot all you
[ __ ] yeah we even made the
material cheaper and you still like it
what we cut corners on this one you
still like it
the iPhone 5c you know what the C stands
for it stands for cash has [ __ ] we
taking all of your money
you see with this one the trick is to
add a lot of bright colors to attract
the female gender much like the baboon
when he presents his big bright red ass
and of course we have another iPhone
coming out called the iPhone 5s
you know what the S stands for same [ __ ]
with the iPhone 5s you can also expect a
lot of innovative technology such as
fingerprint recognition which translates
to the most useless [ __ ] on earth can I
ask you something what the are you doing
with your life then you got to protect
your [ __ ] with the fingerprint huh
[ __ ] you ate that special what let me
guess your face somebody's gonna steal
your identity let me take some if I
stole your identity I'll kill myself
here's something a little funny remember
what Siri came out all you guys were so
surprised and shocked by his technology
that you were amazed and your jaw just
dropped right guess what Siri sucks
monkey balls and here's a little
something else for you did you know that
Siri is racist yeah
racist no go ahead this is what I want
you to do I want you to go ahead get
Siri and see if Siri recognizes you with
your accent do it now see petting me
where I heading to go I don't understand
you [ __ ]
oh yeah Siri why don't you tell me by
the destination I didn't find anything
oh my god I don't tell me what the
reason the mayor Siri why don't you tell
me where the closest supermarket LLL I
don't know what that means
see if I don't you tell me where the
closest convenient place is for the
motel didn't find anything
I don't get anywhere the closest
convenient native 20 more dad you know
what phone I really like is that Samsung
Galaxy did you see the size of that
screen though is beautiful the screen
has a great resolution and I still don't
understand why till this day basketball
players buy the iPhone for example Shaq
you know damn well that iPhone it like a
tic-tac and your big ass Sasquatch hands
with your big ass index fingers your
pinky alone can open up seven apps in
one push and I know this has nothing to
do with the phone but did you guys see
that foot in that Buick commercial
[ __ ] you fit in that car I saw that
commercial your kneecap was directly in
your Adam's apple iphone find the same
[ __ ] over and over again give us your
money
looking at me I'm just going oh you [ __ ]
about this job I'm rich [ __ ] god